he is going to be having a state visit
to the UK if he does a speech in
Parliament you planning on Boehner will
definitely not for many reasons but I
think this thing about the judgement
really is a very important moment in the
u.s. and also for the wider world
because what he's done is he's
criticized the judge that has said this
blanket ban on people coming from Muslim
countries is unconstitutional and has
struck it down now Trump's appeal
against that has been rejected and Trump
was criticizing the judge calling him as
so-called judge and the point is that in
our democracies what we're supposed to
have his elected people but the elected
people are not above the law and
therefore the rule of law must cover
government and government must act
lawfully and I really the worry is that
Trump is going to try and somehow
override the the law and the worry is
not just for America that actually even
the president must obey the law but for
all other countries where people are
struggling for their rights and where
the courts are important to prevent
government abusing their powers so it's
a real constitutional crisis now Trump
versus the rule of law and the
Constitution so how should the UK react
vent birth well they should be saying
that not just in America but all around
the world people look to America and if
America says well governments above the
law we can do what we like once we're
elected even if it's abusing people's
human rights then that's a very bad
message and may should be sending
signals through to reason a should be
sending signals through to the Trump
administration saying don't undermine
the rule of law it's absolutely
fundamental whoever knows what he's
going to be doing next will probably
find out on a tweet now you've been in
Westminster for 35 years you've
certainly seen a lot number of ups and
downs that in your time there but
perhaps nothing quite like the situation
that labor finds itself in now it does
seem to be in somewhat of an existential
crisis the polls are pretty abysmal
you're hopelessly divided on brexit
you've got two big by-election tests
coming up here in stokin in Copeland is
now the time for the Labour Party to
look
to collaborate with other laughing
parties like the greens and then of
dance I don't think so and I I think you
know there are painful echoes of the
1980s and what was happening to the
Labour Party in the 1980s to what is
happening now I mean then we were
divided we were lagging behind in the
polls you know we were in a lot of
difficulties and then people said oh
they'll have to be a realignment of UK
politics you know the Labour Party will
have to merge with the Lib Dems and
actually what it needed was for labour
to get its act together instead of
shouting at the public and telling the
public they were getting it wrong we had
to listen to them and understand where
we were getting it wrong and that's what
we've got to do again so certainly I
think we're not in the situation we want
to be in we really need to sort
ourselves out but I don't think it's an
existential crisis I think it's a very
bad time and that's a problem because we
do need a strong opposition at a time of
you know when we're going through brexit
it's interesting that you draw this link
between what's happening now what's
happening in the 80s it's something you
mention as well in your book when you
talk about these days back in the 1980s
when left-wing party members were
shouting at MPs to resign when local
party meetings were wrought with
arguments and this was your conclusion
in the book we can have a quick quick
look now you said infighting turned the
public off voting for us is that
happening now is Labour unelectable in
its current state I think that it causes
great worry amongst our supporters and
turns off is unelectable right now which
I so well no we're not unelectable we
have loads of elected Labour MPs but you
mean are we an effective opposition and
are we a credible alternative government
I think you can't be an effective
opposition if you haven't got enough
public support because the government
doesn't need to worry about you they
only look at their own side they don't
they don't be concerned about us so we
do need more public support in order to
be an effective opposition let alone a
credible alternative government we have
definitely got work to do so you're not
an effective opposition now it seems to
be what you're saying I think we're not
as effective as we could be because we
haven't got public support so it's no
good having the right arguments or just
speaking very loudly you actually have
to have the public on your side to make
the government take
you know she's of you at all and of
course one of the big areas where
perhaps there is a need for an effective
opposition is brexit labor is very
divided on brexit and potentially the
situation isn't helped by leading mps
like Diane Abbott not showing up for the
vote on article 50 well I think the
country's divided on brexit I know that
you know those of us who wanted remain
we lost and the leave one so we are
going to have brexit but that doesn't
change the fact that actually the
country was pretty much split down the
middle and I think the Labour Party
overall was very much in favor of remain
but it's the tactics now that the party
is divided on not the principles we
still want to make sure that the social
justice economic prosperity we want the
country to be united all of those
principles remain the same but
tactically it's very difficult and you
know when you're in opposition often
it's only bad choices you don't set the
context and therefore it's a very
turbulent time but I don't think we're
divided in principle we're just some
divided in tactics I hate to vote for
article 50 because I wanted us to stay
in the EU but I recognize that that
decision was taken in June we've got a
ratify it in the House of Commons but
we've got to make the best of the bad
situation we're in for the country and
make sure the government do as well as
they can for the country and not make
things even worse so it's clearly a
difficult decision for MPs like yourself
particular who have remain areas that
you represent in Parliament's so how
disappointed worried that Diane Abbott
didn't show up for this vote well you
know she said she was ill and unable to
vote and I think you know you just have
to accept that I've known other empires
had cancer in mind to me well I know but
you see I've known in the past where
people have criticised MPs and it did
turn out they were ill I remember when
mo Mollen was was very unwell and the
newspapers all jeered at her and
actually you know she had a you know she
had a very serious illness I'm not
saying Diane's got a serious illness I'm
just saying give people the benefit of
the doubt and the other thing is that
Diane had actually been on TV saying she
was going to vote for article 50 so
she'd already taken the flak on it so
I'm just assuming that she didn't vote
because she wasn't well but anyway you
know what was quite ironic is that we
had 400 MPs plus going through the
division
I'll be labor and Tori's the
overwhelming majority of them didn't
want to be voting what they were voting
for but because there's been a
referendum we we sort of had to ratify
it so it was like the unhappy not
happiest unhappiest night of voting in
the House of Commons I've ever been in
for all the MPs that were in the
division Lobby but since the referendum
was lost well we just have to get on
with it
now I'm interested to talk about your
time as a woman in Westminster ever
since you enter the house of the Commons
it seemed that you were determined to
try and focus relentlessly on women's
issues you've been pretty relentlessly
criticized for that by some quarters
calling you
Harriet Harper said in your book you
talk for example about some Labour MP
seeing you as a humorless feminist have
there been any times when you've like
gone back to your office and had a good
cry about it
or wanted to quit well not you know not
crying about it but I've certainly
especially when the children were young
in the early days it just felt too much
because you know I was part of the
women's movement we wanted to get into
Parliament and change everything but
it's one thing knowing what you want to
do is quite another when you meet real
opposition especially from your own side
so I did want to quit a lot but I
promised my constituents that I would
fight for them and I was part of the
women's movement and we knew that
getting change would be hard so I had to
stick it out but the main purpose was
not just having women MPs for the sake
of it but because women still lead very
different life from men women still have
most of the responsibility for childcare
and for the care of older relatives you
know it's women who suffer most from
domestic violence there's there's a
whole load of issues which are important
for women and women's voices need to be
there in the House of Commons otherwise
those voices get overlooked a labour of
course have put lots of women in the
House of Commons but something where
you've been slightly less good is
getting women in the top jobs I'm just
going to show you now the women who run
for the Labour leadership in the past
and I find it astonishing that they've
all placed below men so women have come
bottom whenever they've run for the
Labour leadership I mean what's going on
his labour got a problem with women well
it is a bit of a paradox isn't it
because we've got more labour women MPs
than all the other parties put together
and yet we don't seem to be able to get
a Labour leader who
a woman and in fact at the moment we've
got two men in the leadership the the
leader and the deputy and that is a
problem for the party that is the party
of women and of equality which Labour
prides itself on being you know how come
it is it that the Tories can get not
just one woman Prime Minister but two
for heaven's sakes so we have got to
sort ourselves out on that but it's not
just having a woman at the top it's
actually having the policies that you
know like childcare and things like that
look really help women in practice so so
but I just want to go back to this point
because I just think it is for a party
that prides itself on women's issues and
equality every woman who's run has
placed below a man in the Conservatives
every woman who's run has placed above a
man what's going on there must be
something in labour that makes it harder
for women to get to the top well if I
knew what the magic you know it is
paradox if I knew what the sort of magic
problem I mean the problem was and we
could just throw a switch and change it
but I mean certainly I think everybody's
more and more people are beginning to
recognize that it just looks downright
old-fashioned to think that you know men
have to make the decisions and women
have to abide by them I mean I was
brought up at a time when there was the
old phrase that men were men and women
were glad of it well we just need to
move a bit beyond that the Labour Party
I think and of course you've served
under many of these male leaders that
we've had how would you rate Tony Blair
Gordon Brown ed Miliband or on their
record on promoting women and
encouraging women's issues to the
foreground well I first came in whether
it was Michael foot and you know that
was really before the days of the
women's movement had really got going
into politics Neil Kinnock was a real
strong supporter of women in politics
and Tony Blair presided over a hundred
Labour women coming into the House of
Commons and loads of policies that
helped change things Gordon Brown
doubled maternity pay and leave and he
also didn't you Deputy Prime Minister
yeah who didn't you know which he should
have done and I should have made him but
you know that's you know another story
so I think that it's it's down to all of
us it's not just down to the the leader
it's down to all of us to say okay you
know it can't just carry on like raining
men in the Labour Party men at the top
I've got to share power with women that
hasn't happened yet but it's got to it's
part of really changing labour too
you know the modern equal Progressive
Party we ought to be you say men the top
haven't shared power with women does
that also apply to Jeremy Corbyn of
course he was criticized initially for
not putting women in the top jobs well I
wouldn't you know jeremy corbyn's leader
now but I mean it's been the same old
same old you know he's not the first
person who's not had you know who's been
leader in a not yet equal labor party so
I think it's it's work in progress but
we need to get a move on and he should
do more well all leaders you know
obviously we should be doing more to
make sure that this equality happens yes
of course he should be retial all should
be and I'm also keen to get your
thoughts on social media which feels
like it's a new challenge for women in
politics you know these horrific stories
of rape threats of you know death
threats on some occasions what do you
think's going on in society that we have
a situation where women have to put up
with this well I think it's this whole
issue about social media and bullying
and threatening on social media is not
just a question for women in politics
it's a question for for women and
especially young women all around and I
think that actually the women in the
House of Commons many of whom who've
suffered this are going to be the people
who will help sort it out because many
young women and girls lives are made an
absolute misery by what is going on
online and it's a wonderful way of
communicating of course it's an amazing
sort of digital revolution but actually
it's got a dark side and we need to make
sure that we keep progressing with all
this you know digital engagement but we
deal with the worst elements of it and
actually the women MPs who've had death
threats you've had rape threats you know
they've been at the sharp edge of it
they definitely know how bad it feels
and they'll be the ones that will drive
getting it sorted out and of course some
of the worst abuse has come from some of
the left-wing
members or supporters at the Labor Party
some of it is been done in jeremy
corbyn's name even if he himself has
calmed it does he need to be stronger oh
yes he does I mean what he says is I
don't condone it and it's not being done
on my behalf but when you're a leader
you have to do more than that you have
to say I'm against it I condemn it and
this is what I'm going to do about it to
stop it and then do that so I think
being a leader is not just saying it's a
bad
thing it's doing something about it do
you think he's failing women in the
labour party by not doing one I think he
should take action about it not just say
I'm not in favor of it you know it's not
good enough to say it's all awful when
you're the leader of the party you're
actually in a position to do something
about it
just a quick thought from you err - and
Harriet do you regret not running for
the Labour Party leadership yourself
well in a way I do and I think the
moment I should have run is in 2010 when
Gordon stood down but it sort of took
everybody by surprise because we thought
he would stay and handover and then I
became acting leader and suddenly
realised I could do it at that moment I
should have set forward and it's a bit
of a mystery to me why I didn't but I
think the world is full of men who are
not up to the job pushing themselves
forward and loads of women who are up to
the job who don't him for that moment I
was probably one of them fortunately
people like you Sophie are surging
forward thank you very much Harriet
Harman